[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir les lions de la teranga
accueillis comme des héros une marée
humaine a envahi les rues de dakar la
capitale des dizaines de milliers de
personnes se sont massées devant
l'aéroport léopold sédar senghor moins
de 24 heures après la victoire du
sénégal à la can la fête ne fait que
commencer nous serons à dakar dans ce
journal le jour d'après à madagascar les
dégâts sont considérables après le
passage du cyclone tropical bats hirai
il a épargné les grandes villes mais
laisse derrière lui des dizaines de
milliers de sinistrés le bilan fait état
d'au moins vingt morts et dans ce
journal je vais vous raconter l'histoire
de comédie dingue cela signifie montre
ce que tu sais faire il s'agit d'un
cheval qui a permis à son propriétaire
d'entrer dans le cercle fermé du monde
des courses sud africain aujourd'hui on
le surnomme le cheval du peuple
reportage de nos correspondants dans ce
journal
le rêve éveillé des lions de la teranga
accueilli par des dizaines de milliers
de supporteurs à l'aéroport de dakar les
joueurs sénégalais rentre en héros au
pays les apportent avec eux la coupe
d'afrique des nations une coupe
longtemps mérité mais obtenue après
beaucoup de patience en revient sur
cette ambiance de folie avec nos
correspondants à dakar sarah sakho et
élimine d'eau
c'est un véritable triomphe pour les
lions accompagné par une marée humaine
dans leur traversée de la capitale dakar
jusqu'en centre-ville et au palais
présidentiel où ils seront reçus par
macky sall macky sall qui les avait déjà
accueilli en fin d'après-midi à
l'aéroport militaire léopold sédar
senghor au pied de l'avion il ya eu une
petite cérémonie kalidou koulibaly le
capitaine de l'équipe s'étaient exprimés
il avait chaleureusement
remercié le public sénégalais de leur
soutien tout au long de la compétition
soutien qui at il dit leur a permis de
remporter cette coupe en tout cas les
sénégalais ils ont été patients ils ont
attendu toute la journée certains depuis
le matin devant l'aéroport militaire où
était prévu l'arrivée des héros du jour
je vous propose d'écouter ces réactions
ont régalé on remercie le team national
pour le dévouement et le travail qu'ils
ont fait pour nous rendre heureux tous
les sénégalais faire ici pour faire la
belle c'est celui-là pour sa demande en
berne mais ni parce que nos volumes et
les avait menacés mesure préférée oise
somme là où subi les faire la fête à
l'école ça a été une très très très très
belle can qu'ils ont fait on est très
fiers de ce télégramme tout 35 vivre
aujourd'hui
le programme est loin d'être terminée
demain mardi les lions sont de nouveau
reçu au palais présidentiel dans l'après
midi pour se voir remettre par le
président macky sall la plus haute
distinction sénégalaise
les tunisiens qui est pour
l'indépendance de la justice après cette
nouvelle décision de caisse aed le
président tunisien a dissous samedi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
une mesure qualifiée de nouvelle dérive
autoritaire par ses détracteurs pour
rappel le président tunisien avait
suspendu le parlement élu et limogé le
gouvernement le 25 juillet dernier
depuis il gouverne par décret les
explications de notre correspondant à
tunis lilia blesse
c'est une décision qui suscite
l'indignation au sein de la magistrature
qui s'est exprimée par l'intermédiaire
de secor associatifs et syndicaux via
des communiqués publiés ce lundi ils ont
tous exprimé unanimement leur refus de
la décision de kayes sayed de dissoudre
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
qu'il accuse de partialité et de
corruption ce conseil avait été créée
par la constitution de 2014 et devait
assurer le bon fonctionnement de la
justice ainsi que son indépendance face
au pouvoir exécutif alors pendant
plusieurs années comme d'autres
institutions de l'après révolution il
avait été en proie à des polarisation
politique est parfois critiquée même en
interne par des magistrats qui avaient
appelé plusieurs fois à sa réforme mais
jamais à sa dissolution comme l'a décidé
kaïs ayed dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
aujourd'hui la société civile se dit
préoccupé de la non séparation des
pouvoirs en tunisie qu'implique cette
décision mais aussi d'une décision qui a
été prise dans une période d'exception
où aucun recours n'est possible et où il
n'ya pas de contre-pouvoirs puisque le
parlement est toujours suspendu la
diplomatie européenne s'est aussi dit
préoccupé et a insisté sur l'importance
de préserver l'indépendance de la
justice en tunisie et que s'il devait y
avoir des réformes elle devait se faire
de la façon la plus inclusive possible
aujourd'hui cayenne n'a pas encore
publié le décret de mise en application
de cette dissolution
direction la guinée cinq mois après le
coup d'état qui a renversé le régime
d'alpha condé le conseil national de la
transition qui doit décider de la date
du retour des civils au pouvoir a tenu
samedi sa toute première réunion une
décision qui va dans le sens des
exigences de la cedeao la correspondance
à conakry de malik diakité
au cours de cette toute première
rencontre les 80 ans membre du conseil
national de la transition étaient tous
prison la séance qui a duré environ
trois heures s'est tenue au palais du
peuple à conakry en présence des
représentants de chaque parti politique
de certains ambassadeurs de la
sous-région accrédités en guinée et de
nombreux militaires qui ont renversé le
président alpha condé le 5 septembre
dernier au cou micro de france 24 ses
conseillers ont tenu à exprimer leur
engagement pour un retour des civils au
pouvoir j'ai conscience que le
changement radical des mécanismes qui
amène les élites au pouvoir et qu'il
permette de s'y maintenir coisy
indéfiniment doit être définitivement
résolus nous devons écrire une
constitution qui ne sera pas facilement
modifiable par les pouvoir constituer le
maximum sera fait pour ne pas décevoir
la confiance qui a été placée en août
sera en contact de façon permanente avec
le peuple pour qu'on trouve une durée
que la population doit accepter la
guinée est où je suis le coup des
sanctions de la cedeao l'organisation
sous-régionale exige des putschistes un
calendrier précis pour un retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
à madagascar a été balayé par le cyclone
tropical à bâtir high heel et a
désormais quitté la grande île mais les
dégâts sont considérables le cyclone a
épargné les principales villes mais
laisse dans son sillage des dizaines de
milliers de sinistrés 20 morts et des
récoltes rasé faisant craindre une
aggravation de la crise humanitaire
laurent baer stecher
accablé incrédules les habitants de ma
jeune jarry constate les dégâts
toi souffler bâtiment éventré arbres
déracinés
le cyclone bats hirai a tout emporté sur
son passage
toutes nos maisons ont été détruites
les eaux sont montées et tout s'est
effondré
c'était vraiment terrifiant
le cyclone a frappé la côte est de
madagascar dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche avant de se déplacer vers le
centre de l'île et s'il a largement
épargné les grandes villes bâties rail a
provoqué d'importantes inondations
détruisant les récoltes dans une région
considérée comme le grenier à riz de
madagascar
les organisations internationales
redoutent une aggravation de la crise
humanitaire dans un pays déjà menacées
par la famine l'impact cyclone ne se
termine pas aujourd'hui l'impact du
cyclone va durer plusieurs mois
n'oublions pas qu'en parallèle
madagascar est frappée par une
sécheresse qui demeurent dans le sud est
par la crise politique qui fragilise son
économie
la principale route de madagascar a
également été endommagé par le cyclone
impactant l'acheminement des aides
humanitaires
un coup dur de plus pour le pays encore
sous le choc de la tempête tropicale ana
qui s'était abattu sur l'île fin janvier
les funérailles du petit ryan au maroc
après cinq jours d'espoir et de
tentatives de secours l'enfant tombé
dans un puits est décédé il a été inhumé
ce lundi près de son village dans une
région déshéritée du nord du royaume la
mort de ryan a déclenché une émotion
considérable amplifié par les réseaux
sociaux au maroc et dans le monde entier
cette nouvelle charge virulente du
premier ministre malien l'encontre de la
france je gueule mes gars qui a pris la
parole devant un parterre de diplomates
en poste à bamako a accusé la france
d'avoir le site devrait à la partition
de son pays à travers son engagement
militaire une charge qui a duré 45
minutes le premier ministre malien n'a
par ailleurs pas demandé explicitement
le retrait de la force anti djihadisme
arcanes conduite par paris
le 35e sommet de l'union africaine il
s'est tenu ce week end à addis abeba en
ethiopie c'est le président sénégalais
macky sall qui prend la présidence
tournante de l'ua après le mandat du
congolais félix tshisekedi
dans son discours d'ouverture moussa
faki le président de la commission de
week-end à pointer du doigt les lacunes
de l'ua face au défi du terrorisme et
des coups d'état à répétition vous
propose d'écouter moussa faki et le
président sénégalais macky sall
la militarisation du continent africain
c'est vrai c'est un coup d'état en moins
de deux ans ça donne l'impression que
l'afrique du sud elle revient aux années
70 où des coups d'état militaires
étaient légion
c'est absolument inadmissible dont qu il
appartient à mon sens l union africaine
aujourd'hui
de travailler sur des textes encore plus
rigoureux encore plus dur sur les
interruptions
anticonstitutionnel de pouvoir et que
les auteurs de ces actes plus être
immédiatement non seulement sanctionner
mais que le pays
le pays qu'il dirige immédiatement
sanctionnée à tous les plans
pour finir je vous emmène en afrique du
sud avec cette belle histoire un homme
d'origine modeste qui ne fait pas partie
des cercles traditionnels du monde des
courses sud africain a fait fortune
grâce à un cheval qui lui a coûté une
bouchée de pain et il est désormais
surnommé le cheval du peuple et fait
rêver toute une frange de la population
nos correspondants caroline du mais ses
fans car celles ci l'ont suivi
il est 7 heures du matin on capte
l'entraînement commence tôt pour les
chevaux de course
mais la star de cette petite écurie de
banlieue c'est comme hedging il avait
gagné le grand prix de durban en juillet
dernier son propriétaire est venu
l'observer
juste avant la plus prestigieuse course
de l'année
c'est un cheval qui nous a toujours fait
des surprises ça c'est sûr jamais je
n'aurais imaginé que ce cheval me
positionnerai un jour à ce niveau jamais
à jean est un ouvrier du bâtiment qui
n'a jamais eu de cheval il a acheté
celui là il y a deux ans 2500 euros
contre tous les pronostics le poulain
s'est avérée exceptionnelle pour son
entraîneur c'est un véritable conte de
fées il a été acheté avec un budget
relativement faible les gens réalisent
que devenir réalité un rêve devenu
réalité pour aschwin qui a investi dans
une quarantaine de chevaux grâce à
comédie ding qui lui a permis de gagner
son premier million de rands les
sud-africains surnommé le cheval du
peuple
les gens l'adorent et beaucoup de jeunes
notamment de jeunes noirs me demande
comment faire pour acheter un cheval de
course en bas
âge une est fier d'avoir pu entrer dans
le cercle fermé du monde des courses sud
africain et pour le grand jour son
numéro 5 était le favori de tous les
parieurs mais dans la loge privée du
propriétaire on est restés nerveux
jusqu'à la fin
[Applaudissements]
ajout il a dédié sa dernière victoire à
son grand père qui lui avait donné la
passion des courses sans cheval vaut
désormais des millions mais il a confié
à son cousin qui ne le vendrai jamais il
m'a dit est ce que tu te rappelles quand
on était petit pour tourner aux courses
ici en bas pendant l'apartheid alors que
les gens regardaient la course sur les
balcons euros j'ai bien tout ça c'est
fini c'est pour ça que je ne vendrai
jamais ce cheval parce que c'est à nous
maintenant d'être debout là haut est de
laisser tout le monde nous regarde pas
le cas hasna
comédie d' il n'a que 4 ans deux ans de
moins que ses compétiteurs et une
magnifique carrière devant lui
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]
ces derniers jours la tension est montée
d'un cran au mali le sentiment
anti-français et l' influence russe qui
gagne en puissance échauffe les esprits
sur fond de nationalisme et de
panafricanisme entretenue par la junte
militaire
vraiment content les sens du mot de
passe
les pays du sahel sont tentés de suivre
ce qui est appelé la voix malienne fait
de coup d'état et de populisme alors que
la période est critique pour
l'engagement militaire français dans la
région
travailler dans le sens de rapprocher
les
[Musique]
ombres heureuses sur le mali un reporter
à voir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme
au plus fort de la crise sanitaire elle
distribue plus de 600 repas par jour on
est au plan d'aou dans les quartiers
nord une vue imprenable sur marseille
mais qui ne laisse en rien oublier
qu'ici plus d'une personne sur deux vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté les femmes du
plan d'aou l'action contre la faim
cédant pas de quartiers pas de quartier
à voir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme